- [Voiceover] In this
video, we're gonna look at
another familiar pattern of resistors
called parallel resistors.
And I've shown here two
resistors that are in parallel.
This resistor is in
parallel with this resistor.
And the reason is it shares nodes.
These two resistors share the same nodes.
And that means they have the same voltage.
And they are called parallel resistors.
So if you share a node.
Share the same node.
Then you share the same voltage.
And you are in parallel.
That's what that word means.
Now, if we go look closer here,
we'll see some interesting things.
It's hooked up, we have a battery here,
some voltage v.
And because there's a path,
a complete path around here,
we're gonna have a current.
We're gonna have a current i
flowing in this circuit.
Let's label these resistors.
Let's call this one R
one and this one R two.
Those are our parallel resistors.
When the current reaches this point here,
when a current reaches this node,
it's gonna split.
It's gonna split into
two different currents.
That current and that current.
We'll call that one i one,
because it goes through R one.
And we'll call this one i two.
And that goes through R two.
Now, we know any current
that goes into a resistor
comes out the other side.
Otherwise it would collect
inside the resistor,
and we know that doesn't happen.
This one comes here.
And they rejoin when
they get to this node,
and flow back to the battery.
So the current down here is again i,
the same one as up here.
Now, what I want to do
is I want to replace these two resistors
with an equivalent resistor,
one that does the same thing.
And by "the same thing," we mean
causes the same current to
flow in the main branch.
And so that's what's drawn over here.
Here's a resistor here.
We'll call this v again.
And we'll call this R parallel.
R P.
And this resistor causes the
same current i to flow here.
And now we're gonna work
out an expression for that.
We want to figure out
how do we calculate R P
in terms of the two
parallel resistors here.
Okay, so let's go at it.
What we know,
let's see what we know
about this over here.
What we know is the voltages
on the two resistors are the same.
We know there's two different currents,
assuming that these are two
different-valued resistors.
And now, with just that information,
we can apply Ohm's law.
And we use our favorite thing, Ohm's law.
Which says that voltage
on a resistor equals
the current in the resistor
times its resistance.
So let's write down Ohm's law
for R one and R two.
Okay, we know the voltage,
we'll just call the voltage v.
This is for R one.
v equals
i one times R one.
And for R two, we can
write a similar equation,
which is v, same v,
equals i two R two.
Now there's one more fact that we know,
and that is that i one
and i two add up to i.
And these are the three facts
that we know about this circuit.
What I'm gonna do now
is come up with an expression
for i one and i two
based on these expressions,
plug them into this equation.
Okay, I can rewrite this equation
as i one equals v over R one.
I can write this one as i two
equals v over R two.
And now I'm gonna plug
these two guys into here.
Let's do that.
i equals i one,
which is v over R one
plus v over R two.
Let me move the screen up a little bit.
Okay, now we're gonna continue here.
I just want to rewrite this a little bit.
i equals v
times one over R one
plus one over R two.
Okay, so here we have an expression.
It actually sort of looks like Ohm's law.
It has an i term, a v term,
and this R term here.
Let me go back up here.
Here's our original Ohm's law.
I'm gonna write this,
I'm gonna solve for i in terms of v,
just to make it look
a little more obvious.
I can say i equals v over R.
And what I hope you see here
is the similarity between this equation
and this one down here.
So I have this R here.
And what's happening is this term
is playing the role of that, resistance.
So I'm gonna bring this
equation down here,
and write it right down here.
Times one over R.
I'm gonna call this R P.
Because what I want is
for this expression and this expression,
I'm gonna set those equal.
Same i, same v.
These guys are equal.
I can write it all, I'll
just write it over here.
One over R P equals
one over R one
plus one over R two.
This says we have a resistor,
we're gonna call it R P or R parallel,
that acts like the parallel
combination of R one and R two.
So this
is the expression for a parallel resistor.
If you want to calculate a replacement
for R one and R two in parallel,
you do this computation and you get R P.
So let's do one of these for real.
Here's an example.
Here's an example where I've
actually filled in some numbers for us.
So I have a 20-ohm
resistor in parallel with
a 60-ohm resistor, driven
by a three-volt battery.
And what I want to do is I want to combine
these two parallel resistors and find out
what is the current right here.
Find out what is the current,
that's my unknown thing here.
I know everything else about this.
So let's use our equation.
We said that one over R P
was equal to one over R one
plus one over R two.
And let's just fill in the numbers.
One over R P equals one over 20
plus one over 60.
That equals, let's just make
60 the common denominator.
So I have to multiply this one by three.
Three over 60 plus one over 60.
And that equals four over 60.
And so now I'm gonna
take the reciprocal here.
R P equals
60 over four
or R P equals
15 ohms.
So what this is telling us
is if we have two resistors in parallel,
20 ohms and 60 ohms,
that is, for the purposes of
calculating the current here,
that's the same as 15 ohms.
It took the three volts.
Just like that.
Let's check what the current is.
The current is i
equals v over R
equals three volts over 15 ohms.
That's equal to 0.2 amps.
Or you can say it's the
same as 200 milliamps.
So we actually have now
simplified our circuit
from two resistors to one resistor.
And we were able to
compute the current here,
which is 0.2 amps.
And I would invite you to check this
by going back and computing
this current up here
to make sure it's the same.
And the way you would do that
is you would calculate the voltage.
The voltage here is three volts.
Three volts across 20,
three volts across 60.
You'll get i one and i two.
And if you add those together,
you'll get the total i,
and it should come out the same as this.
And I think that's a good
exercise for you to do,
to prove that the expression
for a parallel resistor,
one over R parallel can be computed
from one over R one
plus one over R two.